pourquoi je suis ici
oui parce qu'il faut que je fasse son
devoir
il ya combien seulement 0 1% de
survivants ce qui signifie que pour un
seul survivant diamil tués
si avant j'étais rongé par l'inquiétude
aujourd'hui j'ai bien peur qu'il n'y ait
simplement plus d'espoir pour vos
soldats
pour nous tous
[Musique]
comme vous le savez déjà un événement
s'est produit il ya vingt-quatre jours
nous avons perdu le contact avec la
quasi totalité du monde toutes les zones
à l'extérieur du cercle de vie ont été
plongés dans l'obscurité
[Musique]
tous ceux de la zone de quarantaine dont
nous attaquer
160 millions d humains
pas tout à fait
je ne sais absolument pas à quoi on doit
se préparer si tu as trop vite c'est
peut-être moi
la guerre a commencé
à
[Musique]